[Musique]
qui ne voyait pas d'issue à sa maladie
mais par contre il savait très bien
qu'en partageant
le mari d'Irène avec un souhait au
moment de mourir donner tous ces organes
pour sauver d'autres vies mais sa
volonté n'a pas été complètement
respectée
[Musique]
dizaine de personnes meurent au Québec
chaque année en attendant une greffe qui
ne vient pas des organes sont gaspillés
est-ce que la population en entend
parler est-ce que les gens qui sont en
attente en entendre parler c'est sûr que
non
pendant des mois en quête tentées de
suivre une transplantation ce qui nous a
été refusée mais par contre on a
découvert que notre système de don
d'organe au Québec manque de
transparence et que personne ne semble
avoir de compte à rendre ici Marie Maud
Denis bienvenue à
marketing
et tout à coup Marc est venu pour parler
puis il a réalisé que
il parlait comme s'il était en état
les examens ont suivi et ce que ça leur
vraiment confirmer la Sclérose Latérale
la myotrophique et la forme bulle bas
donc la forme la plus rapide donc quand
vous êtes devant lui non il voulait pas
vivre non pas jusqu'au bout donc il le
vérifier s'il pouvait avoir droit à la
médicale à mourir et effectivement il
était candidat à l'aide médicale à
mourir donc ça a été sa décision
qui ne voyait pas d'issue à sa maladie
mais par contre il savait très bien
qu'en partageant
en faisant
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on s'habitue facilement à
respirer avec ça avec une bonbonne comme
ça
[Musique]
s'appelle
[__] moi j'ai testé de mourir à 20 ans
même on s'est rendu au centre
hospitalier à Fleurimont et là on va
patientait on a attendu et un moment
donné l'infirmière de Transport Québec
c'est présenté dans la dans la chambre
et c'est l'organisation
que finalement les poumons seraient pas
pris
pas besoin de vous dire que on était
sous le choc
[Musique]
maladie vieillesse accident la mort peut
frapper n'importe quand mais au milieu
de toute cette douleur de ce drame il
peut aussi y avoir une source de
réconfort un geste qui donne un sens à
ce qui n'en a pas le don d'organe
[Musique]
puis je me dis il y a quelqu'un qui
aurait pas avoir ses poumons là puis
cette personne là est-ce que cette
chance là à leur pensée je sais pas on
se voit jamais
aidez vos proches à faire valoir votre
volonté d'être donneur d'organe au
moment de votre décès dites-le comme
vous voulez mais dites-le nous sommes
tous invités à signer notre carte pour
consentir au dons d'organes
mais est-ce que tout sera fait pour que
notre volonté en tant que donneur
potentiel soit respecté et que l'une des
888 personnes au Québec dont la vie ou
la qualité de vie dépend d'une
transplantation pour en profiter
[Musique]
c'est pour ça faut que j'assis parce que
la Gaspésie c'est plutôt dans
deux ans
et demi
attend depuis près de 5 mois sa greffe
de poumons
on peut sauver jusqu'à 8 vies en donnant
nos organes à notre mort le cœur les
poumons le foie qui peut être divisé en
deux le pancréas l'intestin est de reins
on peut en améliorer des dizaines de
plus avec des tissus comme les cornets
la peau les os les veines et les tendons
le problème c'est que les donneurs sont
très rares il faut mourir à l'hôpital
bénéficier d'une ventilation mécanique
et d'un soutien médical il ne faut pas
souffrir de cancer généralisé ou
d'infection incurable en fait environ 1
à 2% seulement des personnes qui meurent
à l'hôpital peuvent donner leurs organes
je travaille dans les soins intensifs
j'ai malheureusement trop souvent à
annoncer des mauvaises nouvelles puis
j'ai appris très très tôt même avant
même d'avoir fini ma formation que
d'offrir l'option ton d'organe quand on
a perdu la partie pour sauver la vie de
quelqu'un pour la plupart des familles
pour beaucoup de familles c'est une
source de soulagement de savoir que
malgré les malheur qu'il vivent ils
peuvent quand même sauver des gens donc
si je ne peux plus rien faire pour la
personne que je devais sauver je peux
encore faire quelque chose pour cette
famille là qui souffre si je suis
nerveux
dans le cas de Marc Saint Laurent le
mari d'Irène les deux reins et le foie
ont été prélevés je suis pas capable
d'accepter que les poumons non conjoint
n'ont pas été utilisés parce que moi je
sais que mon conjoint il y avait des
très bons poumons
la dernière partie de tennis a été le 20
octobre il y a eu la médicale amoureux
de 17 novembre s'il y avait pas eu des
bons poumons il n'y aurait pas pu jouer
il y a un peu plus de 20 ans le Québec
faisait bonne figure en matière de dons
d'organes
utilisé le plus souvent pour mesurer la
performance des pays ou des régions dans
ce domaine c'est le nombre de donneurs
d'organes décédés par millions
d'habitants
j'ai rencontré tous les cas de travail
de mon hôpital le symbole qui représente
la cause du don d'organe ça va être une
source de soulagement s'il souhaite
faire le don d'organe quand les gens ont
une greffe que ça va bien le docteur
Pierre marcelet est profondément engagé
depuis des années dans la cause du don
d'organe
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en raison de problèmes de
santé il travaille de chez lui
malheureusement ça me fait mal de le
dire au Canada le Québec a été un chef
de fil jusqu'à il y a quelques années et
puis elle m'a donné un moment donné on a
perdu du terrain juste pour donner un
exemple en 2000-2001 le Québec était
au-dessus de la France et aujourd'hui la
France est loin devant nous c'est comme
si nous on fait du surplace depuis une
vingtaine d'années
l'écart est encore plus marqué avec des
pays comme l'Espagne et les États-Unis
nous sommes en dessous de la moyenne
canadienne notamment lorsqu'on se
compare à l'Ontario en 2019 avant la
covid le taux de donneur par million
d'habitants était de 26,1 chez notre
voisine comparativement à 21,3 pour le
Québec
[Musique]
il y a eu deux moments où le Québec
aurait dû élargir son bassin de donneur
d'organe ici on a les Dana par million
de population au Québec de du début des
années 2000 jusqu'à 2006 alors qu'on ne
faisait que les données après décès
neurologiques jusqu'en 2007 on a prélevé
des organes que sur des donneurs en état
de mort cérébrale mais cette année-là on
a aussi commencé à le faire après des
décès d'origine cardio-circulatoire
puis en 2010 Québec adopte une loi qui
oblige les directeurs des services
professionnels des hôpitaux à signalé
tout donneur potentiel mais rien de tout
ça n'augmente le nombre de donneurs de
façon significative
ça a pas bougé donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on est saturé on n'est pas
capable de faire plus
attention on traverse avec le foie
la partie qui s'en va
on prend le foie
qu'on va transforme
quand on fait des sondages pour dire je
vais vous prêt à donner vos organes
au-dessus de 90% bon dire oui alors
c'est pas que les Québécois sont pas
prêts à donner c'est que l'organisation
ça c'est beaucoup l'organisation mais on
fait pas nécessairement le maximum pour
être capable de rester en tête de liste
depuis 2016 les Québécois peuvent avoir
recours à l'aide médicale à mourir et
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
vouloir faire donc de leurs organes mais
on peut se demander si le Québec
réussira cette fois à profiter de cette
nouvelle occasion d'augmenter les dons
d'organes
on a rencontré une veuve Irène trépanie
dans le mari a eu recours à l'aide
médicale à mourir et il a voulu donner
ses organes et finalement les poumons
n'ont pas été retenus pour des raisons
que cette dame là s'explique mal est-ce
que ça vous étonne ça ce genre de
situation là je suis pas étonné est-ce
que c'est acceptable non un c'est trop
puis on sait qu'il y en a probablement
pas eu juste un dans ce genre de
situation là est-ce que la population en
entend parler est-ce que les gens qui
sont en attente en entendre parler c'est
sûr que non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais je serais curieux de savoir combien
d'organes passons on n'entend jamais
parler combien d'organes qui finalement
qui est à viable qui n'ont pas été
utilisés ça j'aimerais ça le savoir
j'aimerais ça le savoir
c'est une très bonne question et après
la pause on va tenter d'obtenir des
réponses
n'a pas été transporté pourquoi il était
refusé pourquoi c'est comment et on
adressait la question à chaque fois à
chaque fois qu'elle vient de
quand quelqu'un meurt à l'hôpital et peu
et veut donner ses organes ça doit
absolument être signalé à transplant
Québec mais souvent ça ne se fait pas on
manque des occasions de sauver des vies
et personne ne le sait et ça pour des
médecins qui sont spécialisés là-dedans
qui croient aux dents d'organes c'est
inacceptable en 2022
c'est vraiment
tout ton monde s'écroule c'est surtout
la perte de ton autonomie
la Sclérose Latérale a mis le trafic
c'est une maladie neuro dégénérative qui
les muscles s'atrophie ça nous empêche
d'utiliser nos gens
d'utiliser nos bras
d'utiliser
notre salive nos muscles dans la gorge
s’attrophie aussi ce qui fait que on est
plus capable d'avaler
et on est plus capable de respirer
[Musique]
c'est quand je vais être rendu à ma
limite
être capable de respirer et d'avader que
vous allez décider d'y aller
quand ce moment viendra Linky Boutot
aura recours à l'aide médicale à mourir
et elle espère donner ses organes même
s'il lui faut pour cela se rendre à
l'hôpital et renoncer à mourir dans le
confort de sa maison
et surtout j'ai appelé avec transplant
Québec que maintenant mais notre famille
va savoir
quels organes ont été donnés
vont savoir vers un main que j'ai été
utile jusqu'à fin de ma vie le 17
novembre 2020 peu de temps avant de
recevoir l'aide médicale à mourir Marc
Saint-Laurent et sa conjointe Irène se
font expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles les poumons ne pourront pas
être prélevés
il pouvait pas prélever les poumons
parce que les manquait de matériel pour
faire fonctionner un appareil qui fait
comme un traitement aux poumons avant de
les greffer je dis voyons ça
cet appareil c'est le système de
perfusion ex vivo pour le poumon cette
technologie avant-gardiste développée à
Toronto permet d'évaluer et de
stabiliser des poumons une fois qu'ils
sont à l'extérieur du corps humain
le centre hospitalier universitaire de
Montréal le chum qui est le seul à faire
des transplantations pulmonaires au
Québec l'utilise depuis 2014 dans les
cas d'aide médicale à mourir
l'utilisation de l'appareil ex vivo est
obligatoire au Québec pour éviter des
tests trop invasifs sur des donneurs
encore vivants
[Musique]
donc ils ne veulent pas toujours venir à
l'hôpital pour passer plusieurs tests
alors nous n'avons parfois que des
informations limitées la machine ex vivo
permet une évaluation bien plus précise
le docteur Marcelo salpel fait partie de
l'équipe qui a mis au point l'appareil
de perfusion ex vivo le programme de
transplantation de poumons du réseau
universitaire de la santé de Toronto est
l'un des meilleurs au monde
[Musique]
dans une nouvelle ère nous ne faisons
pas qu'évaluer les organes avec
l'ex-vivaux nous réparons maintenant des
poumons endommagés
comment un grand centre de graisse le
sang de grève au Québec manque de
matériel c'est inconcevant
c'est des vies qui sont au bout de ça
irait une Trépanier refuse d'en rester
là elle va exiger des explications
[Musique]
mais d'abord un petit cours accéléré
pour comprendre à quel point le
processus qui mène à un don d'organe est
complexe
à part dans les cas liés à l'aide
médicale à mourir ou c'est prévu
d'avance c'est une course contre la
montre qui nécessite une coordination
colossale
le personnel de l'hôpital doit d'abord
identifier le donneur puis vérifiez
auprès de transplant Québec s'il a
accepté de donner ses organes en pleine
crise il faut ensuite approcher les
familles et obtenir aussi leur
consentement
transplant Québec doit alors
identifier un receveur compatible selon
les listes d'attentes et de priorités et
contactez le médecin spécialiste du
receveur pour voir si l'accepte l'organe
pour son patient s'il y a plusieurs
organes potentiels il faut contacter
plusieurs spécialistes il faut ensuite
trouver les chirurgiens pour prélever
les organes et les chirurgiens pour les
transplanter
pendant ce temps il faut faire des tests
et maintenir les organes en vie si le
donneur n'est pas dans un centre désigné
de prélèvement il faut le déplacer dans
un autre hôpital les chirurgiens des
hôpitaux où seront greffés les organes
doivent s'y rendre pour prélever les
organes tous en même temps et vite
repartir vers leur hôpital pour les
transplanter enfin il faut trouver une
salle d'opération pour le prélèvement et
une ou plusieurs pour les
transplantations
tout ça le plus rapidement possible pour
éviter la détérioration des organes et
le découragement de la famille qui
risque de changer d'avis
[Musique]
quand on vous parlez avec des gens qui
fait cette sorte du travail et on
commence de faire des études et de se
parler on voit que il y a des moments où
on a des manques et c'est partout dans
la processus
le docteur Samara
aux soins intensifs de l'hôpital de
Montréal pour enfants c'est en côtoyant
de jeunes patients en attente d'une
grève d'organe qu'elle a commencé à se
poser des questions sur le système de
dons et de transplantation d'organes au
pays
qui sont là pour des semaines des mois
et ça devient comme une partie de notre
famille ici parce que on sait la tente
est toujours longue et on commence de
poser la question à ce que
est-ce que la grève va arriver et ça va
venir deux ou et comment la système
fonctionne pour que cette petit enfant
va être va recevoir leur deuxième chance
à vivre
pour l'intentioniste pédiatrique le
premier problème survient à l'étape de
l'identification des donneurs potentiels
si mon collègue
pose pas la question à la famille
malheureusement leurs proches et à la
fin du vie il y a une autre patient en
caldrie à Ottawa qui est sur la liste
d'attente qui peut mourir qui peut avoir
des complications parce que il attend
plus longtemps mais on le voit pas parce
que c'est pas on avant de nous on ne
connaît pas leur nom on connaît pas leur
visage c'est un événement qui devrait
jamais arriver
depuis 2010 on l'a dit la loi au Québec
oblige les hôpitaux à signaler les
donneurs potentiels mais les
statistiques de transplant Québec
indiquent que certaines régions en
réfère très peu par rapport à leur poids
démographique un exemple Laval ces
hôpitaux en référé 1% des donneurs de la
province en 2021
[Musique]
mais donc dans le moment on pourrait pas
me donner un chiffre de dire on a manqué
l'année dernière tente d'honneur après
révision des dossiers médicaux non pas
précisément surtout parce que on est en
train de réviser nos critères aussi
pourtant ces données sur les donneurs et
les organes manqués on les a colligés
pendant un certain temps au Québec les
docteurs l'Allier et marcelet faisaient
partie de ses comités qui relevaient de
transplant Québec j'étais sur ces
comités-là qui évalué à chaque mois tous
les décès dans les hôpitaux puis on
regardait les décès qui avait été
manqués ok pourquoi ce règne là n'a pas
de sensé pourquoi il était refusé
pourquoi c'est comment et on adressait
la question à chaque fois chaque fois
qu'elle vient de mort ce genre
d'exercice là on le fait pendant 10 ans
de 2006 à 2015 mais pourquoi on a mis
fin à ses comités là en 2015
les dirigeants de transplant Québec de
cette époque ne sont plus en place mais
l'organisme nous écrit que par rapport
aux efforts considérables consentis en
temps et en ressources ces comités
apportaient peu de gains significatifs
[Musique]
Saint-Laurent ont été gaspillés elle
veut que les responsables lui rendent
des comptes dans une réponse que j'ai
reçue d'un dirigeant du charme c'est que
pour lui je pourrais vous lire
textuellement
écouter c'est écrit dans les
circonstances entourant le don d'organe
de votre conjoint l'équipe de
transplantation pulmonaire a jugé que le
risque était significatif les conditions
des organes chez un patient maintenu
artificiellement envie aux soins
intensifs par exemple en vue d'une
transplantation n'est pas la même que
celle d'organe prélevé suite à l'aide
médicale à mourir il n'y a pas de
garantie que la possibilité de
l'appareil ex vivo aurait changé le
cours des événements
c'est la réponse que j'ai
le shume le centre hospitalier
universitaire de Montréal laisse donc
entendre que les poumons venant de
donneurs décédés à la suite de l'aide
médicale à mourir serait plus
problématique pourtant ce n'est pas ce
qu'on constate ailleurs
nous avons fait près de 50 greffes de
poumons provenant de donneur qui ont eu
recours à l'aide médicale à mourir et
vraiment il s'agit d'organes de très
bonne qualité
voulait pas des poumons de mon conjoint
là c'est le rôle de Transat Québec c'est
transplant Québec qui normalement
devrait offrir justement les organes qui
sont refusés ici au Québec les offrir à
une autre provinceau
alors automatiquement ils nous sont
offerts puisque nous sommes le centre de
transplantation le plus proche c'est
comme ça qu'on a eu plusieurs donneurs
venant du Québec
mais transplant Québec a informé Irène
Trépanier que les poumons n'ont pas été
offerts à l'extérieur de la province
après ses réponses Irène reste
convaincue que les poumons de son mari
étaient viable le jour de son décès il a
même effectué quelques pas de course
écoutez les voisins 5h30 le matin le
voisinage était sorti dehors pour saluer
Marc pour une dernière fois fait le
marque son manteau il est parti puis
étaler à l'encontre des voisins étaler
les saluer une dernière fois
le même fait des petits pots de course
[Musique]
notre enquête sur le don d'organes se
poursuit après la pause
[Musique]
au Québec on avait une formule unique au
pays pour les dons d'organes un centre
dédié pour les prélèvements à l'hôpital
sacré-cœur à Montréal mais ce centre-là
il faut en parler au passé il n'existe
plus chicane de clocher rémunération des
médecins est-ce qu'on l'a fermé pour les
bonnes raisons
je demanderai à tout le monde d'observer
s'il vous plaît une minute de silence
à mon avis on avait un joyau et ont été
même les avant-gardistes on a réussi à
ouvrir les portes qu'il fallait pour
rendre une chose possible on avait un
joyau on avait probablement des
meilleurs systèmes au monde puis on le
brisé
[Musique]
au centre de prélèvement des organes qui
l'a créé à l'hôpital du sacré-cœur de
Montréal plus communément appelé le CPO
un projet pilote qui a existé entre 2013
et 2019 en réponse à des problèmes
identifiés depuis longtemps dans
l'organisation du don d'organes
une source de soucis une source de
compétition de ressources dans un
hôpital ça va décourager les
professionnels je vais donner les
ressources à celui qui vivent pas encore
sauver le vivant puis le donneur
cadavérique sera toujours perdant parce
que lui il est mort puis la personne ou
la personne a sauvé sont loin on les
connaît pas
le projet pilote de sacré-cœur était
unique au Canada pour favoriser le don
d'organe dans un système de santé déjà
surchargé l'idée était d'avoir des
services centralisés le CPO offrait deux
lits aux soins intensifs et une salle
d'opération dédiée entièrement au don
d'organes avec des équipes de garde 24
heures sur 24 7 jours par semaine
qu'est-ce que ça changeait pour un
chirurgien transplantation le d'avoir un
centre non
donc s'il y avait un autre urgence une
césarienne ou n'importe quoi la salle du
don fonctionne
le centre de prélèvement des organes
s'attirent des éloges la responsable des
dons d'organes et de tissus à Swiss
transplant vient même à Montréal pour
s'en inspirer
déjà avec également une bonne prise en
charge de donneur avec ce bloc dédié
avec cette équipe qui nous occupe que
des données d'un organe c'est exactement
ce qu'il nous faut on a fermé le CPU en
selon vous pourquoi
pourquoi parce que on avait au départ
mais la ministre elle elle affirme que
les résultats et la rentabilité du CPO
n'était pas au rendez-vous ça c'est
froidement réducteur c'est une engage
administratif pour dire que la CPO ça
coûte trop cher nous ne pouvions pas
laisser une rémunération trois fois plus
élevée qu'ailleurs au Québec pour les
mêmes résultats monsieur le Président
pourquoi on a fermé ça il y a eu des
très bonnes années il y a eu des autres
années c'était très semblables aux
autres centres donc on a fait révision
de ça avec avec le gouvernement et le
gouvernement a décidé que
l'investissement comme c'était structuré
ne valait pas la peine
le projet de la vie professionnelle de
Pierre Marcelin vient de s'écrouler
catastrophique il passe des heures à
scruter les rapports d'évaluation du
ministère pour comprendre leur
conclusion selon lui ils sont truffés
d'erreurs que vous avez constaté c'est
que les chiffres sont pas bons là
qui malheureusement peut orienté des
gens quand ils regardent de façon
critique ben non le CPU a pas conféré
davantage parce que ils passent leur
analyse sur des erreurs en 2016 le
docteur marcelet a réussi à convaincre
le ministre de la Santé de l'époque
Gaëtan barrette de préserver le CPO en
lui présentant son analyse rejetant les
conclusions du ministère
data marcelaine
il m'a dit le docteur barrette c'est un
des seuls qui a pris le temps de
vraiment regarder les données tout le
monde qui était présent reconnu que mes
affirmations étaient vrais et que les
per du centre était supérieur à ce qu'on
disait c'est un fait ça vous pouvez me
confirmer au cours des deux premières
années 388 organes ont été transplantés
provenant en provenance des donneurs
prélevés au centre de prélèvement
d'organes
a permis de transporter 388 organes
alors que le plus proche rival en avait
fait 218 et le suivant 194 ainsi de
suite le CPU des servait un million
300000 personnes mais en 2015 transplant
Québec réduit ce bassin à 840 000 le
nombre de donneurs potentiels diminue et
la performance du centre s'en ressent
nous avons parlé à plusieurs personnes
qui ont été mêlées au dossier du centre
de prélèvement des organes au-delà des
raisons officielles pour expliquer sa
fermeture il y a aussi eu tout un jeu de
coulisses d'abord autour des primes
d'environ un million de dollars par
année qui était versé à l'équipe de
médecins spécialistes de l'hôpital du
sacré-cœur vu de l'extérieur on ne peut
pas savoir qu'il y a eu des gars de
clocher et je vous dirai même qu'il y a
eu des jaloux
parce qu'il y avait des sous attachés à
ça
on nous a aussi confié que des grands
hôpitaux universitaires trouvaient que
le CPO leur portait ombrage et enfin que
la personnalité intense de pierre
marcellay en dérangé certains
si on fait la
soirée quand est-ce que ça va
à cause de ça si ça fait trop de
problèmes
sinon on commence
à mon avis pour l'individu mais c'est
aussi dramatique pour la société et
certainement pour ceux qui dans la
société sont visés les papiers en
attente de greffe durant les années
d'existence du centre de prélèvement des
organes on a constaté une hausse du
nombre de donneurs d'organes au Québec
et une baisse après sa fermeture en 2019
quelle influence a eu le CPO sur ses
résultats difficile à dire la crise de
la covid 19 est venue brouiller les
cartes
pour améliorer la performance du Québec
en ton organes le gouvernement mise
plutôt sur le déploiement dans les
hôpitaux de médecins coordonnateurs en
dons et en transplantation d'organes là
où ils sont présents transplant Québec
constate une hausse dans
l'identification des donneurs leur
nombre devrait passer de 10 à 32 cette
année
mais ça ne règle pas tous les problèmes
je sais pas où ça a chopé je sais pas
mais il est arrivé quelque chose du fait
qu'on a perdu ce dedans
un des patients du neurochirurgien
Jean-François Giguère est décédé
récemment à l'hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont de Montréal le
patient avait exprimé son désir de
donner ses organes et son conjoint était
d'accord mais le cas ne pouvait pas être
traité avant plusieurs jours ce qu'on me
dit qu'il y avait en même temps
plusieurs donneurs avaient plein qui ne
peut pas faire face à la demande
j'ai l'impression que c'est un problème
de ressources et on m'a dit que la
famille était pas capable de continuer
ce deuil là pendant plusieurs jours donc
ils ont décidé
nextubation ililatérale et un décès sans
pouvoir donner les organes selon
transplant Québec le temps requis pour
procéder au prélèvement des organes et
le principal obstacle au consentement
des familles parce que souvent ces délai
là c'est parce qu'on n'a pas de
ressources pour envoyer quelqu'un pour
traiter les demandes c'est inacceptable
que quelqu'un qui souhaite donner ses
organes on n'est pas capable de traiter
de dossier on est capable de on est
obligé de perdre
ce cadeau là qui sont prêts à offrir
juste parce qu'on n'a pas de ressources
pour traiter de dossier en 2014 ce délai
d'attente entre le consentement de la
famille et le prélèvement des organes
était en moyenne de 35 heures
il avait plus que doublé le temps
d'attente moyen était de 86 heures
au retour Irène rencontre Lucie qui
suppose les mêmes questions
on nous parle tellement de l'importance
des dons d'organes partout on nous dit
il faut signer nos cas faut facile pour
faire ça puis la journée que ça arrive
ça marche pas ça fonctionne pas
[Musique]
quelle ténacité quand même d'Irène
Trépanier qui multiplie les démarches
pour comprendre pourquoi les poumons de
son mari n'ont pas été prélevés mais les
pas seul Irène parce qu'avec l'aide
médicale à mourir il y a de plus en plus
de proches qui sont témoins des ratés du
système et qui demande des comptes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est avec beaucoup de
respect de gratitude que nous sommes
réunis pour rendre hommage aux donneurs
d'organes et de tissus du Québec avec
beaucoup d'émotion aussi chaque année
l'Association canadienne des donneurs
d'organes et de tissus organise une
grande cérémonie pour honorer les
donneurs et leurs familles ainsi que les
policiers bénévoles qui assurent le
transport des équipes médicales et des
organes
et les résolu que le titre d'ambassadeur
de la santé en 2021 144 personnes au
Québec ont donné leurs organes après
leur décès
moi j'ai toujours dit s'il m'arrive de
quoi je donne mes organes puis là lui a
dit mais moi aussi je dois faire pareil
quand on a mon mari a décidé de donner
ses organes aux autres ont pensé que
c'était comme des films
toutes plus données mais c'est pas mal
complexe que ça
le mari de Lucie Vachon André Massot a
demandé l'aide médicale à mourir le 28
juin 2021 il est décédé trois jours plus
tard il était aussi atteint de la SLA
plus connu sous le nom de la maladie de
lougirrig il avait 57 ans
[Musique]
était pas assez beau que le pancréas il
y avait pas été gardé non plus que les
reins savaient un succès puis que les
poumons ben on pouvait pas les donner
parce que le délai entre le temps qu'on
a décidé de d'obtenir les médicaments
Québec ça donnait pas cette étape
trouver un receveur faire les tests
appropriées pour valider les poumons et
ainsi de suite
quand tu décides de donner des organes
tu t'abandonnes au domaine médical tu
t'informe pas parce que tu dis si les
autres les experts mais il y a encore
des lacunes
[Musique]
Irène Trépanier a poursuivi ses
démarches elle a fait appel à un avocat
pour obtenir les dossiers médicaux de
son mari
[Musique]
j'ai reçu de la part du chou-fleurimont
les documents qui prouvent que les
poumons de mon conjoint étaient bons ok
Marc avait passé des tests à deux
reprises en fonction respiratoires
nous avons montré les documents au
docteur Sepel le chirurgien thoracique
de Toronto il confirme que rien dans ce
dossier n'a dit que les poumons
n'auraient pas pu être prélevés un autre
chirurgien marque de Perrault est du
même avis
rapport du scanner de fonction
pulmonaire l'historique il y a rien de
particulier à mon
alors n'ont-ils pas été prélevé Irène
trepanier espérait enfin obtenir une
réponse claire dans les documents de
transplant Québec chers
demandé le dossier puis écouter ça a été
non
votre demande a été traitée en
application de la loi sur la protection
des renseignements personnels dans le
secteur privé et suite à être analyse
nous concluons que nous pouvons pas vous
transmettre les documents relatifs avant
de demande d'accès en raison de
l'article 41 de la loi sur le secteur
privé ils disent qu'ils sont un
organisme privé mais dans le fond privé
oui c'est vrai peut-être mais qui vivent
de subventions que monsieur et madame
tout le monde paye avec les impôts
est-ce que c'est normal ça ou que les
gens aient pas de réponse claire à ce
genre de questions là pour moi
je suis pas au courant des détails tout
cas et même si j'étais au courant de
détails de cas j'aurais pas le droit
d'en parler et le décision pour ça ça
reste chez les programmes de graffeur
mais d'avoir des discussions
où on peut vraiment discuter le pourquoi
de ça plus en détail je te fais d'accord
que il faut qu'on fasse mieux la
critique va pas juste ça transpant
Québec je suis pas sûr qu'il y a un
choix gouvernemental de dire oui le don
d'organes doit être une priorité
ministérielle et on va mettre les fonds
qu'il faut pour faire ça j'ai déjeuné
une conférence où j'étais seul il y
avait une personne dans la salle tout le
monde était comment votre été un assez
vie en 2022 c'est normal les gens
veulent soigner du monde pour qu'ils
iris ils veulent pas prendre soin de
quelqu'un qui est déjà perdu et on sait
qu'il y a à peu près à chaque année 250
Canadiens qui vont mourir sur la liste
d'attente et si on peut couper ça c'est
des gens c'est des amis c'est des
voisins
transplant Québec demande un débat
public sur le don d'organes comme il y
en a eu sur l'aide médicale à mourir
tout est sur la table consentement
présumé rôle de la famille dans la
décision révision de la loi pour imposer
plus imputabilité et de reddition de
compte financement et accès aux soins
intensifs et au bloc opératoire toujours
problématique
multi ça nous touche énormément qu'on se
rend compte aujourd'hui parce que
premièrement quand on vit sur les
pression qu'on est toute seule moi ce
que
sembler similaire à nous ça a été le
rejet des organes
à la dernière minute parce que on nous
parle tellement de l'importance des dons
d'organes partout on nous dit il faut
signer nos quatre faut facile faut faire
ça puis la journée que ça arrive ça
marche pas ça fonctionne pas en notant
qu'elle demeure anonyme les familles
peuvent communiquer entre elles par
l'intermédiaire de transplant
québecueil
express my gratitude for the gif ok
est-ce que je peux être certaine qu'on
va tout pour que mes organes soient
utilisés est-ce que vous faites
certaines non il faudrait pas que ce
doute là se mettre dans la tête de tous
ceux qui signent une carte puisqu'il y a
plein de gens qui a six grands pas si
votre famille n'est pas au courant que
vous n'avez pas que vous n'avez parlé
mais pas au courant que vous avez signé
le notaire la carte les affaires la
famille peut encore dire non est-ce que
je peux être certaine qu'on va tout
faire pour que mes organes soient
utilisés
à 100% qui vont être utilisés non parce
que je veux avoir les ressources pour
garantir que ça va jamais arriver
tremblement l'état de situation du don
d'organe aujourd'hui est-elle que nous
n'avons pas créé les circonstances pour
s'assurer
que les organes prélevables chez une
personne arrive à chaque opportunité si
vous mourrez demain matin il faut vous
temps vous ayez la chance de tomber dans
un hôpital où il y a des médecins qui
vont savoir non seulement vous
reconnaître vos stabiliser et aussi
accepter et d'avoir la bonne façon
d'approcher votre famille le faire avec
empathie de l'affaire avec sensibilité
il n'y a pas de groupe de défense et
donneurs d'organes les patients étant
décédé la plupart du temps mais la
hausse des dons d'organes dans un
contexte d'aide médicale à mourir vient
changer la donne les familles sont
davantage présentes durant tout le
processus et donc témoin et elle
commence à poser des questions autant
que Marc ne fait donc d'organe c'était
sa mission autant que moi ma mission
c'était de dénoncer puis d'essayer de
faire avancer des choses pour plus que
ça soit produite je lui ai dit de partir
en paix
[Musique]
mon conjoint me connaît
puis je suis sûr que dans sa tête tu
sais dire elle va s'en charger
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]